[Musique]
alors on va lui demander de venir vous
désignez un joint de temps c'est un
traître
c'était très très gentil garçon pas très
très gentil garçon
ou alors vous essayer à côté mieux
bonjour je suis bonjour comment ça une
série de commentaires
voilà j'ai trouvé comment saison - bah
oui parce que je n'étais pas là nous
avons dit et qualaa lorsque la caméra
est en gros plan maintenant sur vous
michel serrault bien sûr il est idéal
des neuf que vous l'ayez demandé dans
votre émission ça me surprend tout le
monde vous savez c'est une idée oui
c'est une idée mais j'aime bien parler
avec michel et je les ai encore des
choses que je n'aime bah oui mais bien
sûr oui ou non on n'aura pas le temps de
dire de toute façon je sais pas si
certains sujets dont on ne va pas
pouvoir aborder dans moi j'aime j'aime
bien parler avec michel parce que c'est
parce que c'est un homme avec lequel je
peux parler de tout ensuite intervient
rendent métier est intéressant que
sérieusement c'est qu'on a toujours
l'impression que ces duos et des duos
qui se prolonge par le ps que le succès
de qui se prolonge et que c'est
presqu'autant des délais diu d'intérêt
que d'amitié ans dans votre cas c'est
vraiment de l'amitié vous êtes vraiment
amis est lié je vous en prie vous
appelez professeur bouzid et de solidité
on va s'appeler professeurs maîtres du
jeu
je crois vous savez que c'est comme
c'est comme dans comme dans un couple
comme dans un ménage une question
d'intérêt quand on parle d'intérêts il
ya toujours il ya toujours un intérêt
sordide eux je veux dire si on est
ensemble
si on fait ça vire ensemble ou si on
fait une partie de sa vie
professionnelle ensemble c'est parce que
on a un intérêt un intérêt mais dans le
sens de la vie en commun c'est à dire
qu'on s'intéresse aux mêmes choses on
s'intéresse aux mêmes formes au mef
en l'occurrence aux mêmes formes
d'humour aux mêmes formes de comique
et puis je crois que nous
nous sommes jamais saturé l'un l'autre
nous n'avons jamais trop empiéter sur
nos vies sur nos vies d'hommes à l'un et
à l'autre
et puis très vite nous nous sommes
séparés pour jouer pour jouer michel
d'un côté moi données les moins que
votre association elle a duré tellement
d'années mais finalement ça fait
longtemps vous jouez séparément aussi
mais nous on a joué souvent séparés
violent on était toujours ensemble ou au
cabaret ou au théâtre
enfin je veux dire hier pendant très
très longtemps c'est pas quitter
finalement mais on était effectivement
peut-être les gens je vois une pièce
parent ou tu as joué fleurs de cactus
je jouais monsieur blot sont là ils vont
se retrouver le soir
donc ça fait très longtemps qu'on ne se
quittent pas bien entendu on côté la
cage aux folles vous avez joué quatre
enfants nous sommes retrouvés nous
avions joué auparavant à vaudeville
anglais qui s'appelle vison voyageur
nous sommes retrouvés là et puis bon
michel l'échelle a fait du cinéma mais
je la tournée et puis nous nous sommes
retrouvés pour la cage aux folles et est
à nouveau là bon
j'ai créé une pièce un bon gps vous êtes
geder pour michel pour moi pour moi je
ne sais pas où ça va il ya toujours le
problème quand on est quand il ya
toujours le problème des d'équilibré des
rôles de trouver de trouver là sa pâture
mais j'avais une rivalité entre vous
honnêtement comme ça a coûté la ferme
l'origine allumé la plus grande de
rivaliser
je veux pas parler de d'années parce que
ça fait quelques années si on avait eu
je préviendrai au bout du bout de trois
mois donc on a d'abord à sion et à leurs
jours disait par exemple qu' il ya des
affinités et en même temps je crois que
c'est très important c'est en même temps
qu on fait notre métier de comédien le
temps passé nous vivons comme nous
sommes des gens le disaient des gens
quand même très près du métier bien sûr
c'est une autre vie et je veux dire que
vous comprenez que en même temps si on
ne s'entendait pas bien s'ils avaient
pas quand même entre nous une grande
amitié venir ça serait ne serait pas
possible parce que ce qui est important
c'est de le temps passe nous vivons je
veux dire de nous le temps notre vie en
même temps qu on fait ce métier on fait
par son métier dont va pas l'aider on va
faire son métier pendant 30 ans et on va
vivre trente ans après n'est ce pas en
attendant ce qu'on a tendance au début
d'une carrière a conscience et je
l'essentiel rien et qu un équilibre à
trouver justement entre le travail et
puis les gens qui concourt en compte
c'est pour ça qu'il faut que la ville
voulait ressentiez la même manière
chalumeau mes suppositions pas possible
présidente
alors avec jean ça fait quelques années
quelques mois qu'on travaille jamais
vous êtes d'accord sur les événements du
monde serveuse jugement je vous tenez
vous dis la même chose profondément oui
bien sûr oui bien sûr parce que où ça y
est vous savez il ya cette chose
fondamentale dans un
disons qu'ils ont produit au dans une
association dans toutes les associations
pour moi le critère c'est de ne pas
avoir à aller au bout presque d'une
phrase au bout d'une idée pour être
compris par son partenaire jamais jamais
nous avons travaillé ensemble nous
écrivions ensemble dans les séances de
travail
jamais
il est arrivé à michel jamais il m'est
arrivé à moi de dire et donc j'ai pas
compris ce que non elle exprime une idée
de et ça ça dépasse notre cadre ce qui
fait qu'il ya effectivement un petit
groupe de personnes avec les avec lequel
nous aimons nous retrouver nous aimons
être sur les personnes il faut
travailler dans ce métier sur la même
longueur d'onde
alors on parle on parle de chapelles
quand on veut être déplaisant mais pas
du tout c'est la même longueur d'onde
parce qu'il faut il faut ne pas avoir à
expliquer aux gens il faut il faut être
surtout dans le comique même en garde on
croire dans le métier mais aussi sur le
reste
bah vous savez je m'en tiens au centre
d'un coût d'opération ddd des numéros
qu'on pouvait avoir ça ressemblait des
choses qu'on sentait de la même manière
de jouer la comédie
vous savez je pense que comme par
exemple quand on voit jouer les
comédiens je pense je dis moi comment tu
joues et je te dirai qui tu es
oui je pense que ça se voit à voyez il
ya des familles de gens d'alors il ya
c'est un tout vous avez les mêmes
opinions politiques
je n'aime pas les gays sont toujours sur
le plan humain oui oui absolument
absolument bas parce que je pense je
pense qu'il y a des options qui sont une
grande option et puis après il ya le ca
se ventile avec des nuances je
demanderai pas comment vous ventilé vous
avez déjà joué moi je vous ai dit une
chose très importante c'est qu'on
parlait de collaboration de travail en
commun les gens disaient il y en a pas
besoin de s'expliquer et le plus
difficile dans ce métier c'est pour
faire passer évidemment d'être surtout
dans le comique jean a raison de faire
passer des idées ou des gags vous voyez
si on doit s'expliquer c'est pas
possible il y une chose très importante
aussi
c'est quand on travaille à 2 je le vois
moi par exemple quand on me fait lire un
scénario
quand les gens c'est très difficile de
travailler à deux je veux dire il faut
pas venir on critique il faut venir
écouter ce que l'autre dit et si
possible l'enrichir mais ne pas
systématiquement écouter l'autre n'est
ce pas moi je vois des choses on vous
dit on vous amène une pièce où vous
amène un scénario et j'entends des gens
dire il est très bien mais il faudrait
changer l'histoire ou disparitions de
travail
les jeunes ne travaillent pas sur ce
qu'on leur propose ils sont tout de
suite à côté et pour faire briller leurs
idées c'est pas ça la collaboration dans
mon évident maintenant c'est d'essayer
de comprendre ce que j'aurai explique et
comment ça fait à boudry élémentaire et
complémentaires et alors ça je trouve
que alors c'est aussi bien avec un
auteur c'est aussi bien avec des
partenaires avec des comédiens et c'est
aussi bien aussi avec un metteur en
scène
hélas c'est pour ça que je vous parliez
tout à l'heure nous dire vous ne vous
êtes jamais trouvé en rivalité pas du
tout justement parce que je crois je
crois que nous sommes nous sommes
complémentaires rendez vous avez gaming
envie de fonder une compagnie tous les
deux roues nous a demandé je crois oui
plusieurs fois oui oui on m'a demandé de
l'emmener notre compagnie quand même des
gens de bonne compagnie d'ailleurs que
vous pouvez peut-être jugé
[Musique]